ethiopian refugees at the umrakuba camp
getting ready for a long stay
they use these plastic sheets to top the
ceilings of their new homes
the u.n distributed 480 of them on
sunday
it also provides these bamboo sheets to
be used as side walls
creative ways to cook food are tested
here as well
solar ovens designed to do the job with
no environmental impact
the norwegian refugee council
distributes cash amounts
equivalent to about 25 dollars per
individual if we give them cash they can
buy
whatever it is if that's sim cards baby
milk formula
new clothes and underwear because
they've been in the same clothes for
three weeks now
they can buy all that from from local
traders who are coming into the camp
instead of us spending a lot of money
with logistics
importing items from different parts of
the world
robin and his wife can now buy soft
drinks and biscuits or sweets for their
children
i'm happy but
anything i will to pay i have a child
if you have no food i will pay
by money my child
he can be you'll eat your breakfast
anything the camp is spreading and
slowly turning into a village
with about ten 000 refugees this place
is already crowded and
as more people are still coming the
numbers are expected to grow
the main concern now is that there seem
to be no protection measures here
to prevent a potential outbreak of the
coronavirus in the camp
there is zero social distancing here no
masks
and no kovi tests whatsoever but there
are also
no reported cases of severe illness that
looks like the coronavirus
much more concerning for people like
yavith and his wife is food and shelter
for their 19 days old baby
after many days of sleeping rough with
no ceiling above their heads
they are now going to share one shack
with another family
until they can have their own the baby
was born in ethiopia
making him perhaps the youngest refugee
to cross the border
police name the attack on our village
took place two days after the birth of
our child my wife and i took him
and ran away and hid inside the ditch
for some time
they would have died had we not found
some people who gave us some milk and
food
some of the refugees were themselves
born in this camp
during previous famines and wars gave
birth to their children here
during the current cycle of escape their
future
once again unset mohammedval al-jazeera
um refugee camp eastern sudan